[Musique]
c'est en musique que l'islande se dé
confine dans l'île de l'atlantique nord
les boîtes de nuit ont été autorisés à
rouvrir après neuf semaines de fermeture
aucune règle de dispensation physique ni
imposer mais les soirées sont de courte
durée pour les islandais les
établissements doivent fermer leurs
portes au plus tard à 23h c'est assez
réjouissant de pouvoir à nouveau sortir
voir ses amis et avoir le sentiment de
revenir à la normale bien sûr il ya
toujours cette appréhension de
contracter le virus
mais on essaye de se protéger à l'autre
bout de l'europe en grèce ce sont les
bars et les restaurants qui ont rouvert
le faible taux d'infection de le pays a
incité le gouvernement à lancer la
saison estivale trois semaines plus tôt
que prévu les restaurateurs axer leurs
efforts pour tenter de sauver leur
activité nous avons eu très peu de cas
par rapport à d'autres pays
nous avons eu très peu de morts dieu
merci donc tout le monde devrait venir
en grèce - aspirent aux baraques taris
j'ai beaucoup d'affection pour eux et je
les attends avec impatience
aujourd'hui c'est une belle journée
parce que la grèce c'est le pays de la
joie de vivre et du bien être
nous n'avons pas l'habitude de ne pas
pouvoir aller au restaurant au café de
ne pas pouvoir sortir et nous amuser
c'est une bouffée d'air également de
l'autre côté de la méditerranée les
espagnols ont pu retrouver lundi leur
pelage ou comme ici dans l'île de
majorque
la baignade est désormais autorisé à
barcelone les habitants ont bénéficié
d'un premier allègement avec la
réouverture des terrasses des cafés des
espaces verts après l'ondé confinement
les plus strictes au monde
la ville est différente modifié
beaucoup de choses vont changer à
beaucoup de niveaux personnel ou
professionnel et j'ai l'impression que
les gens sont plus tranquilles aussi
c'est mieux que ce à quoi je m'attendais
ça fonctionne bien nous avons pas mal de
tables occupées et nous nous sommes
adaptés aux normes requises
au royaume uni pays le plus durement
frappé en europe par la pandémie
boris johnson souhaite rouvrir tous les
commerces d'un essentiel dès le 15 juin
et espère comme ses voisins tourner la
page de cette longue période de
confinement